[Music]
and sweet news that goes without saying
Oh submitted by I watched JK religiously
oh thank you because this is like a
church for you a little girl saw a video
of a thief stealing money from a tip jar
and he donut shop and decided to do
something of totty
oh hey mister what are you doing please
you're under arrest
alright so I'm going to play this video
that will show you everything and tell
you everything yes all people much
person look at it for life awesome what
did she do she took money out that
[ __ ] thief put it in put something in
the doll and the child there's two
inches of his name
[Music]
that's all right
[Music]
ah if only my mom but my mom shall need
a video of your money getting tell them
sorry what happened this is my tooth
fairy money sorry that happened how are
we put a [ __ ] neither here
Tom said for as long as seems the owner
of the stone call you I have a free
balloon oh wow
you call inspiration man okay first of
all it's a little big better out in this
world that's amazing
second of all that music was ridiculous
Murderball that kid that thought it was
a little kid that stole my know it was
like a grown-ass woman
oh what a piece of [ __ ] I don't have a
tip sure how much money can you get god
that somebody was going over a race line
in a wheelchair with no legs without
music as is her cute ass notes can I get
any more wrinkly that's all cool this
this kid is giving their Tooth Fairy
money and you're the story of your kid
is giving you Jam I know baby
I think I got explain to this my nephew
wanted to prank me by giving me Jam for
my birthday
because he's probably thinking she
doesn't want this adult [ __ ] boys so he
gave me the jam and he thought it was
hilarious and then he gave me a toy gun
and he was like here's the real one yeah
look how cute she is such a sweet girl
what kind of doll is that like a [ __ ]
feather duster that's what I'm saying I
don't like to stall because we're
teaching this girl how to [ __ ] you clean
the house with that feather duster
katana shop owner and keeping other
curious Cambodian gangster how does name
Chong with two h's that would be cool
busy cleaner ten you
I want you no not if I can't Bodhi I'm
trying to give it the benefit of the
doubt it's all get me donut Cambodia
Chinese all the donut shops in America
are owned by Cambodians yeah it's all of
them can i Cambodian people give me
donut except for Dunkin Donuts but it's
in their thing it's kind of like
Vietnamese with the nails and Koreans
with the liquor stores and the wig shops
you just can't pop you can't touch it
that [ __ ] a girl is like a bug in
doing a solo act right now
but su though I would say either
Cambodian or people that are like to
chow yeah which is basically Cambodian
to chow
Chinese Cambodians they make some
bomb-ass [ __ ] Donuts do diddily no
there you go
hey job oh hold on hold on hold on this
is actually racial [ __ ] right now they
don't do all the fancy doughnuts very
well but they do the basics really well
the lanes doughnuts those powders
educated about the chocolate bars talk
about our favorite don't do it cut the
[ __ ] food conversation what component
what can we do Claire we met Jason
Bourne I've never liked the maple bar
it's one of my favorite the people who
don't like maple bars are racist Oh cuz
they don't like brown eggs yes Andy the
owner of daylight's donut mr. Tong he
posted this video up of or that video of
the grown-ass woman feeling out of tip
jars how you gonna do that [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] when he posted that video
that's when Chloe's mom showed her the
video because she goes there like two or
three times a week so she's like
constantly going to that donut shop so
immediately that same day she was like
okay I gotta give him my money right my
ceremony so after he found that note he
started texting a friend of his who he
knows creates discussion pages and
that's when the friend but he texted
said although that's my daughter I
recognized her her handwriting
Wow [ __ ] you world I'm writing it was
signed her name Chloe no this is dumb
[ __ ] I will recognize her for
high-riding I'm like a kids writing
looks all the change it's not like she's
a genius decipher person she goes I
found her - the handwriting because the
name was on the bottom and the social
italian others also blow the name
Isaac's handwriting I like kids in his
class for real yeah so he writes either
that much better or that much worse
because all the other kids are exactly
the same know if you look at his entire
classroom everything was pretty
different usually the girls have Asian
girls always have the best time writing
so Chloe you went there by yourself I'm
not sure I don't know
about that because I did a good question
I wasn't reporting whether she went
alone or not I do not she's near the top
if she goes out that's all nice
well you know what I'll thing is Chinese
what you're doing is you've got to be
Cambodian you know why my free donuts
for the rest of your life that is not
that is not life nothing is free
you know because of Chloe's act of
kindness a it inspired Andy to not press
charges against that girl
oh why would you press charges if it for
four dollars I would she would motivate
me more to press charges I have to teach
her a lesson that's why well because
that's not an act of kindness that's an
act of justice justice so she's teaching
me justice you know what you have to pay
back your debts so justice is you have
to serve your time if you do the crime I
won't press charges if you eat this
donut they came fresh out the fryer
immediately right now oh that's going to
be so good while it burns your tongue
yes and you can't spit it up and you
can't breathe on it just Krispy Kremes
undulator craving are you starting to
get these like pregnancy cravings or
it's like oh [ __ ] it's taking over I
have to have that thing right now now I
know I just want to doughnut right now
though you're making me crazy that
sounds kind of like a cleaning right now
kind of craving I don't have cravings
but I want that doughnut right now
really bad all those symptoms sound like
a craving it does yeah when you want
something really bad and it just comes
out of nowhere that sounds like a
craving I don't see it guys I just know
if I don't get this [ __ ] doughnut
right now I'm a pocket Smith let's say
you're Chloe right you did this act of
kindness you got rewarded with free
donuts for life do you think you would
redeem that we're words oh yeah yeah
what are you kidding me vodka every
single day I'm like give me a maple bar
Coffee bear claw what did the hungry
donut humble one sniper barber data does
free donuts for light or a dozen
doughnut hole that's 12 the one little
bag you know what happen I keep giving
four dollars yeah sure I'm sure I'm
sharing with my friends I know what you
would have done dude
you would have saw that [ __ ]
steal right and then you be like okay if
it's that easy for him to do it how he
did it for me to do it and then you
would yeah
I just took the cash register I want to
ask them how to make donut and you put
them out of business when you open up
your shop
yep you do a better drink mr. Chong I'm
taking you out of business
the doughnuts man on the corner
- uh-huh I'll be like if I learned the
trade Danette endless money I need we
have like this little sign that says
homeless kid I'm only nine years old
this is the only way I could fund my
school please buy my [ __ ] damn it I
always thought I was funny when you go
to those ghetto donut shops like in the
middle of the hunt or a city or whatever
and some things already come with the
price on it but it only give a [ __ ] like
the Arizona tea is 99 cents and you know
how much is this not a 50 yeah yeah this
is 99 it are like how much of 9 9 mm hot
cheetos don't cover hell they're also
the ones that saw you one cigarette yeah
so even if it is not for individual sale
yeah on the cigarette box at the donut
shop sure - it goes well come to change
Donuts but we also serve tacos and
Chinese food yeah [ __ ] the man to do it
we got a donut shop right here and it's
like it's like one of those
establishments that's been in the city
and it's part of the city so one side is
donuts and the other side is we could go
and refill your five dollar and the
other one either give you sandwiches and
that's accountable to buy a lotto ticket
ha ha and ice cream I love it it's like
a multi-purpose food shop that's [ __ ]
joke it's already like that average
minutes and you could buy our cigarettes
300h go over there Wow and it's always
like the old men in the morning
Asian old men huddle yeah smoke donuts
drink coffee and talk about life when it
was great
remember to jungle now we hit the [ __ ]
away and they could have a conversation
about bananas for an hour
hello matter people do you want to
contact me and everybody else you see go
ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias
instagrams and Twitter's
for more videos click up there baby
[Music]